foreign
number one
if you are going into a field
where an education is needed we are huge
proponents
of a four-year degree we're also huge
proponents of the trades
there's lots of guys that are welders
that are making 120 000 a year while
people with a master's degree in social
work are making thirty eight thousand
so let's just keep in mind what you're
going to earn when you go get a degree
so when you're studying don't study some
left-handed puppetry degree get a degree
in German polka history there's only one
job if you have a degree in German polka
history you have to get a PhD so you can
go teach other people to get a degree in
German Polk history it is the only
possible use for that degree and there's
crap like that all over the place that
people go and do and in the name of all
education is good no all education is
not good for purposes of earning
now is all education expand the Mind
hypothetically some of your minds are so
empty that it's crazy you shouldn't put
stuff in there but um but the uh but but
some of it you know so generally
speaking education is a good thing
generally speaking a lifetime of
learning is something you need to engage
in a hundred percent of you a hundred
percent of us need to engage in a
lifetime of learning if the last time
you read a non-fiction book was five
years ago shame on you turn off Netflix
go read a non-fiction book for God's
sakes learn something all the time for
the rest of your life learn something
read read read read all leaders are
readers
not all readers are leaders but all
leaders are readers so be doing you know
learn learn learn believe in education
all four of my kids got a four-year
degree but the the thing that
universally you cannot defend there is
not one shred of data except mythology
that going to a high-priced famous
School ivy league as an example
that you can justify the extra expense
okay the versus a high of well staffed
well-run State School the University of
Ohio the University of Georgia the
University of Tennessee the University
of whatever you know whatever state you
want to put after that okay or just a
state school in you know the Middle
Tennessee State University as one of the
best broadcast and music degrees in the
world and it is a state school and it's
like eight thousand nine thousand
dollars a year tuition
okay one of my friends is the president
of a major Network sent her kid to MTS
to Middle Tennessee State University in
Murfreesboro freaking Tennessee and
could have could have afforded to send
their kid anywhere but wanted to study
broadcast and wanted to study the field
that that a parent was in and so you
know what we're looking for here is
value in education because education is
important but this idea that you have to
go to a famous School
because it's going to get you a job or
because it's going to get you more money
is statistical mythology there's nothing
to back it up lots of studies saying
it's not true yeah it's virtually
insignificant even in the higher level
grad degrees and this is not our opinion
these are Harvard economists that have
put this stuff out so and that's the
customer doesn't care by the way the
only people that carry your mom and dad
and your grandparents and maybe crazy
Uncle Larry at Thanksgiving because
that's where he went to school you know
so we've got to get over this my nephew
went to Cornell I couldn't care right
nobody cares yeah City learn anything
yeah there's two things that we teach
here one is a degree the only way to get
where you want to go to do that thing
you want to do or is it the best way
if it's no to both of those simple
questions is it the only way or the best
way then I got news for you there's a
different way and increasingly in 2023
it's a whole lot less expensive and a
whole lot less time consuming and that's
the reality of the world we live in and
it's only continuing to shift that
direction yeah so we're pro-education
absolutely it just doesn't always
require a degree we're not pro mythology
yeah and it doesn't require a degree to
be success you are not more likely to be
successful by going to one of those
famous schools it just isn't there
there's no data again Wall Street
Journal did a full survey 78 percent
that's eight out of ten of the CEOs of
Fortune 500 companies the top 500
companies on the stock market graduated
from State schools you know what though
Dave you are statistically significant
hello I found I realized just a second
ago that you are more likely if you go
to one of those big name schools you are
more likely to be broke I shared a story
on the Ken Coleman show just a couple
weeks ago of a guy who went to Columbia
okay Film School oh
three hundred and forty thousand dollars
because he went undergrad and he got a
graduate level degree he's in Hollywood
making sixty five thousand dollars right
now and he was quoted in the Wall Street
Journal saying I could have got this job
without either the four-year degree or
the Master's Degree oh he's exactly
right he could have yeah and so now
that's again that's the film industry so
it's not apples to apples in every
industry you got to have a grad degree
for medicine for science a lot of your
science jobs and a lot of your and
obviously all medical jobs but uh
there's a guy who regrets it and he got
this prestigious degree and he still had
to start at the bottom if you want to
get a business degree at Vanderbilt
University in our town here the southern
ivy league if you will sure it's seventy
thousand dollars a year University of
Tennessee is twelve thousand dollars a
year so we're saying six times is that
is that degree six times more valuable
at Vanderbilt than it is at the
University of Tennessee I'm a hundred
percent sure it's not because I graduate
from the University of Tennessee and
people that graduated from Vanderbilt
work for me
oh by the way football team's better at
UT well that football that's it that's
but yeah I mean it's just I just had to
throw that out I know it has nothing to
do with what we're talking about
absolutely nothing don't pick your
school on your football either that
don't do that don't I'm going please God
don't that's a very good play school
because they have a good foot which by
the way a lot of kids are doing that
party scene yes it's always rated and
everything it's just all this garbage
man so it whether it has a lazy river
there's schools that have a lazy river
that you can Coast down you can float
down a lazy river at a university this
is how asinine this whole process has
become and this is why we have a student
loan debt problem of trillions of
dollars because Congress continues to
make loans to people who want to go to
the lazy river
there you go